[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who's been running through
your girl's mind all day
and also from the police 2020 is almost
over but we have a couple of big
releases to close us out
including the new hulu horror starring
sarah paulsen
before we get into the ending of it
though i think we have to discuss the
overall plot
and though it is relatively simple there
are a couple of nuances here to go over
if you liked the video i'd like it if
you liked it and if you loved the video
then please subscribe as we do
breakdowns like this each and every day
and you definitely don't want to miss
them
anyway run follows mother and daughter
pair diane and chloe
who share a very close relationship
we're told that when chloe was born she
faced a lot of health problems including
arrhythmia
which i've definitely pronounced wrong
hemochromatosis
which i've definitely pronounced strong
and asthma
which are probably pronounced right and
i apologize for being an absolute [ __ ]
all of the time
anyway she also has diabetes and is
paralyzed
which means that she spent the majority
of her life in a wheelchair
because of these afflictions the
character has to take various medication
and though is initially a worry that she
will struggle at university
diane is confident that she can survive
or at least
she says in public in reality diane is a
controlling mother that is actually
drugging her daughter with dog drugs
and not the good ones i know what them
scooby snacks really are anyway
throughout the movie
chloe starts to slowly unearth the truth
about this and we watch as she discovers
things on what they seem
you see diane actually kidnapped chloe
when she was very little
after losing her own baby she has
purposely been keeping chloe under her
control
because of the psychological issues
caused from losing her own daughter
chloe learns of this and attempts to
escape diane's control
but after she foils her attempts to get
away chloe takes matters into her own
hands
she downs a bottle of poison and thus
diane must take her to the hospital to
get her stomach pumped
knowing that she's likely going to alert
the staff to what's going on
diane tries to take chloe home but she
leaves a note for one of the doctors
that causes her to call security
just as diane is about to leave the
hospital chloe puts her foot down
literally and manages to stop diane in
time for the security guards to show up
and shoot her
diane is left apparently paralyzed and
we watch as chloe visits her seven years
later
however a big twist comes at the end of
the movie when chloe coughs up the same
pills that she was being sedated with
and we realized that she's been
returning the favor to diane
and keeping her in a life of paralysis
although it seems like a pretty
straightforward plot and twist
i actually think there's a lot going on
with it and the film has some neat
little
call backs and an overall metaphor that
i think works really well
now firstly we start off with diane
helpless in a bed as she prays for her
daughter to be okay
a wheelchair is pushed towards her by a
member of staff
and this actually foreshadows the ending
of the movie
in that we see diane once more in a
hospital bed
however this time chloe is the one in
the chair and not a helpful doctor who
will
allow her to escape the situation for
better or worse
on the whole i actually think that the
film very much represents a parental
child relationship
and the story of some finding it
difficult watching their kids go off to
college
now the movie is a horror film so it
does take things and subvert them to the
extreme
however i think that throughout the
movie the clues are definitely there
early on in the film we watch as one
parent despairs over the idea of their
child leaving
and though diane seems fine on the
surface we know from the movie
that this won't be the case she brags
about how she'll finally be able to date
and enjoy life once chloe is out of her
hair
but the truth is that she will face a
lot of loneliness
as the one regular person in her life is
going to be gone
this is something that a lot of parents
experience and though they get more free
time
they're also losing the one thing that
gave them purpose for the last two
decades or so
chloe herself is of course a child but
she represents one gaining independence
from their parent in many ways
throughout the movie we watch as she
starts to discover things on her own
operate without her mother's guidance
and at the end she's learned to
literally stand on her own two feet
i'm not sure i'd need to tell you this
but symbolically
standing on your own two feet is very
much a sign of independence
and the further that she gets to gaining
this throughout the movie the more that
she's able to move her feet and legs
at the end of the film we also see as
the roles are reversed
in the parent and child relationship now
if you had
a typical childhood then your parents
raised you
and took care of you when you were
growing up however as you aged so did
they
and it's almost expected that when
you're older and they start to become
frail that you'll take care of them
this is a reversal of the parent and
child relationship
and we watch as things flip with chloe
taking care of diane at the end
now i do actually believe that chloe
loves her mother
and in the final scene she doesn't seem
to be drugging her
in order to be malicious more in my
opinion
it's just because she cares about her
now i know that sounds a bit weird
and and don't call the police on me
again but you have to understand that
chloe was raised believing that this is
how one takes care of someone else
and thus she's doing it for her mother
likely because of the way that she was
brought up
there's a great metaphor of diane almost
receiving karma for the way that she
raised chloe
but it extends far beyond that because
she basically
shaped the person that she would grow up
to be thus
diana is responsible for the position
that she's in
due to the way that she raised her child
the values and beliefs that parents
import on their children will make them
become the person they turn out to be
and thus diane is as much to blame for
this situation
as chloe is now why i think that chloe
still loves diane
is because she calls her mom though we
do know that she has tracked down her
real parents
due to her saying her own child loves
their grandparents
i do think that she still has an
attachment to diane
in order to keep her sedated chloe must
also visit her regularly
and this would take a lot of dedication
especially as we know that it's been
seven years
i kind of feel that diane broke her back
from the fall
and though she was paralyzed chloe has
been visiting her
in order to make sure she can't talk or
tell the staff at the hospital
exactly what's going on could be wrong
on that but if she was able to speak
i don't see why she wouldn't have told
someone what chloe's doing just
just get her out please help help anyway
in summary
i took this movie as being a metaphor
for a parent and child relationship
and how the situations of care are often
reversed
chloe learns to stand on her own feet
throughout the film but she still
doesn't forget to pay back
the one person that took care of her now
because she had a subverted view of how
to look after someone
and this is a horror movie it's a very
twisted way to do so
but i think this psychological thriller
works on a lot of levels because of it
now before we get into our review don't
forget we're giving away three copies of
the marvel phase 2 box set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winners are going to be chosen at
random on the 30th november
so make sure you get involved and best
look to you anyway
what did i think of the film overall i'm
sure you're dying to know
and you might guess that i really
enjoyed it the movie does a lot with the
few characters that are in it
and sarah balson knocks out the park as
this unhinged person
that you almost feel sorry for at some
points when she's standing crying to the
mailman
i really got the feeling that she did
care about chloe more than anything
she just can't comprehend letting her go
because of what happened to her own
daughter
she's willing to kill all those that
would take her away from her
and though she is a completely crazy
person
paulson absolutely nails it now as for
the story
i thought it was great that this came in
at a brisk 90 minutes
and it doesn't waste your time messing
around too much with pointless sub
stories and things that you don't need
to know
it's a really fun ride and i also think
that keira allen who plays chloe is very
grounded
and she gives a believable performance
of someone discovering the truth that
she's basically been living a lie
run feels like a hitchcock classic and
it's very psychological on a number of
levels
if you haven't seen it yet and are
watching this video for whatever reason
maybe maybe just like the son of my
voice
then you probably already know whether
you're going to like it or not
but if you're unsure then i still
recommend that you give it a go
and you all you hate my voice don't you
don't don't lie anyway
run was a lot of fun and overall it gets
an 8 out of 10.
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film so make sure you comment
below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of the mandalorian
which will be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come check us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care
peace
you